et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec joël roux et économiste au cnrs et
président du think-tank the bridge bank
monsieur webb bienvenus bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors on va parler
rapidement de ce conflit un trompe
huawei un ça repose sur des présomptions
donald trump en fait tu penses que les
technologies de huawei pourrait
constituer une menace pour la sécurité à
des états unis on à ce conflit
trump aurait donc du coup away cherche
le marché français c'est bien ça alors
je sais pas si c'est trump 6 et son
administration 6 et des services de
renseignement étasuniens aussi c'est la
justice normalement indépendante aux
états unis mais c'est vrai que coup sur
coup
ça commence à faire beaucoup pourquoi
way qui comprend que ne peuvent plus
développés comme il le souhaitait et qui
cherchent d'autres territoires mais il
ya quand même un enjeu différence et on
n'est pas simplement en termes de
développement de marché là on est en
termes de redéploiement du processus
productif on parle d' usine productive
et c'est véritablement nouveau que roy
way souhaite avoir des usines de
production en dehors de chine c'est une
première et pourquoi selon vous parce
que je pense que d'abord huawei est
l'une des entreprises chinoises sinon
l'entreprise chinoise qui est une vraie
multinationales qui a vraiment un
fonctionnement de type multinationales
relativement classique et les grandes
multinationales
au bout d'un moment cherche à se
rapprocher de leur marché à avoir une
production plus proche de leur marché
plus on voit avec la crise du
coronavirus que les questions de
logistique et de chaînes de valeurs
peuvent être assez perturbé dans quinze
jours il ya toujours une volonté qui est
assez classique de se rapprocher de son
marché et roy s alignent un peu sur
cette démarche assez classique
pourquoi la france puisque d'autres pays
européens alors c'est la deuxième fois
que roy aurait fait le choix de la
france croyait déjà
localisé son site j'allais dire de
[Musique]
son quartier général européen en france
à localiser plusieurs sites de recherche
et développement en france il y en a
plusieurs en europe 1 à 5 en france et
je crois que le choix de la france
s'impose pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
après le break site
les deux grandes économies qui reste
dans l'union européenne c'est la france
et l'allemagne mais la france j'allais
dire à un écosystème de start-up un
écosystème d'un écosystème de
technologie de la ville de l'innovation
qui est très dynamique
un environnement de financement de
start-up qui est très dynamique dont 3
n'en a pas besoin mais rwe va avoir
besoin de fournisseurs va avoir besoin
de partenaires va a beau avoir besoin de
talents qui sont naturellement développé
dans cet écosystème dans la start up
nation française
alors pour l'instant cette annonce de
l'emplacement d'une usine de production
de reuver en france a été annoncée par
ouais mais pas officiellement par le
gouvernement français il n'a pas dit un
mot pour le moment pourquoi les français
en tout cas le gouvernement français n'a
pas l'air fier de ce partenariat
huawei france alors d'abord la france
est un pays libre c'est un marché ouvert
si vous moi nous voulons développer une
usine en france n'ont pas besoin que le
gouvernement le koan ans il n'y a pas
nécessairement ce buzz on l'a bien sûr
revanche roi ou est une entreprise a des
droits mais on parlera or et roy est une
entreprise symbolique mais le montant
d'investissement de 100 millions d'euros
c'est une très bonne nouvelle dont 200
millions d'euros d'investissements 1
milliards de valeur annuelle
c'est une très bonne nouvelle mais si
vous regardez par exemple une usine
automobile c'est cinq fois plus donc ça
n'est pas un investissement considérable
non plus le gouvernement est un peu
occupé en ce moment mais je pense que
d'abord il n'y a pas de besoin d'accord
préalable on voit mal le gouvernement à
interdire
je pense que le gouvernement va
légitimement communiquer sur ces points
là dans un cadre plus large
en fonction de la qualité de la de
l'attractivité du territoire français
sans doute en le liant à d'autres
investissements
dernier point vous l'avez souligné
signaler on ne sait pas encore dans
quelle région
ça va se passer on sait qu'elle est en
jeu aujourd'hui territoriaux de
redynamisation du territoire dans
certaines régions on parle de strasbourg
apparemment alors ce serait strasbourg a
des avantages
voilà je parlais du choix tout à l'heure
entre l'allemagne et la france
strasbourg est une manière de faire le
choix ce tout en ne faisant pas en
restant proche de la ruhr c'est un des
régions potentiellement attractif via la
région lyonnaise et la région
toulousaine ya quelques régions que ça
la région lilloise qui est aussi au
confluent d'autres régions je pense que
là ya sans doute des discussions avec le
gouvernement en termes de réflexion sur
la localisation oui alors pour revenir
sur le conflit trump et huawei ses deux
pieds novembre 2019 que washington
accorde des délits sans fin aux firmes
qui se montrent prêts à collaborer avec
huawei des licences qui sont
systématiquement presque refusé trump a
d'ailleurs menacé de cesser de partager
des renseignements avec les pays
étrangers susceptibles de collaborer
avec huawei est ce que c'est ce que
risque la france aujourd'hui
en acceptant l'emplacement de l'usiné de
production de huawei bon trump tente un
peu tous les coups et puis je les lirais
la sémantique n'est pas très précis
c'est à dire un pays collaborent avec
rwe encore une fois la france est un
état de droit
si on n'a pas de raison valable or rien
n'a pas d'empêcher une entreprise de
s'installer sur notre territoire et
qu'on applique les lois que l'exécutif
laisse des lois qui ont été votées par
le législatif être appliqué ce n'est pas
une coopération dont moi ça me paraît
juridiquement assez peu fondé quand même
joël rue et merci pour vos réponses
rappelle que vous êtes économiste au
cnrs et président du think-tank the
wedge tank merci d'avoir été avec merci
beaucoup